Cass don't give up they don't give a
[ __ ] my cats a killer
I'll do the ruthless ruthless ruthless
just kills everything
anything they can yeah have you ever
seen the numbers for how many things
cats kill in North America now billions
of birds billions alien billions
billions of mammals and billions of
birds
what's so gangsters that kill them and
don't even eat them no there's kill yeah
it's like the support they're monsters
yeah and just brings them and drop some
in my kids beds is the question people
also ask do cats kill birds keep leaving
my Birds and they're dead the fluffy
would never do that
I did see a feather in his fall
well there you know my cat my cat drops
rodents all in my children's hair while
they sleep in her bed
I dropped a rat and my daughter's
bathroom it took a leak in her shower
cap really to mark his territory now the
rat was just scared shitless and was
running rat we could instill a lot like
behind the toilet and stuff and we
finally got it out I might be to the
next a goes to put on a shower cap and
it's just filled with pee rat rat pee
disgusting do you know that you can get
leprosy from armadillos mmm of course I
don't know that